to interpret any planet in any house in
any chart at any time. Here is a simple
technique that quickly and easily lets
you assess a broad range of factors to
get a clear and specific interpretation
for any planet in any house. This is the
same technique that I use in my new
report. So if you get that report, it
will run this technique for your whole
chart and interpret every planet in
every house of your chart. But not just
that, will also interpret all the
planets and all the houses in each one
of your zodiacal subcharts like the
navamsha and so on. So that's available
right now at my site
vicdare.com. What is this technique? It
has four steps. First of all, you want
to identify the resonant symbolism. If
you're familiar with my videos about
planets and houses, you already know
what that means. If you're not familiar
with those videos, you'll get a quick
introduction.
Now, second step, identify the primary
implications of those resonance
symbolisms. And then the third step,
note or figure out the opposite of those
implications.
Finally, as a fourth step, you have to
decide or make a call on which of the
two implications, the primary ones or
the opposite ones are more relevant to
this particular chart. Let's look at
each step step by step. Why don't we
take the example of Jupiter in the 10th
house and look at step one which is
about finding the resonant symbolism. So
for example the 10th house is very
visible and that resonates with the
symbolism of Jupiter which is very
honest. Honest means everything is
visible. So Jupiter in the 10th house
therefore the symbolism is
transparency. Another symbolism of
Jupiter in the 10th house is wise
leadership because there's a resonance
between the planet and the house. The
house is about being dominant and
Jupiter is about being
wise. They're not unrelated ideas
because wise people are usually leaders
and
dominant. So when you have Jupiter in
the 10th house, the symbolism resonates
in the vein of being a wise leader or
leading through knowledge, leading
through guidance.
And the third thing is the 10th house is
about being a leader and Jupiter is also
about being a mentor or a guide. So
another symbolism of this that's
important to identify is
exemplariness,
exemplarship. In other words, the
behavior of Jupiter in the 10th house is
something which sets an example for
others. So now that we've done that work
identifying the resonance symbolism
between the planet and the house we can
move on to step two which is to explore
the primary implications of that
symbolism. What I mean by that is
instead of just having these very heavy
and dense keywords try to open up or
unpack the keywords a little bit to
practical things that you would
recognize in everyday life. So for
example, we said Jupiter in the 10th
house signifies transparency. Well, with
step two, you want to ask yourself, what
does that mean? What does transparency
look
like? So it's
openness,
honesty, and therefore it also has to do
with being ethical, not hiding things,
not lying things, being lawful, being
moral.
So that's what I mean by identifying
some of the implications of the main
symbolism. Let's look at the next thing.
Jupiter in the 10th is wise leadership.
So what does that imply? That implies
that you're very effective in the role
of leading through knowledge. So you're
probably good at being a teacher, for
example, or some kind of advisor or
guide or coach or therapist or parent.
And it also implies that since you are
wise, you must have gotten this wisdom
from somewhere. So you probably studied
or you probably had some exposure to
some wisdom. You're
learned. The third thing about Jupiter
in the 10th house is
exemplariness.
Exemplarship. What does that actually
mean? What's the implications of that?
You can
learn just by seeing how they act. They
exemplify their ideals and their
actions.
So that's steps one and two. Now we're
up to step three, which is to note the
opposite implications. Don't look for
the literal opposite like, well, Jupiter
in the 10th implies being an open
person, so the opposite must be you're
closed person. I don't mean opposite in
that way. What I mean by opposite is it
plays to opposite ends. So for example,
when we went through the Jupiter in the
10th house exercise, everything that we
identified was positive and the person
is honest, the person is ethical, the
person is
moral. So all of those implications are
advantageous to the native or positive.
What you do in step three is figure out
the opposite in the sense of how could
these same traits be disadvantageous?
How could they work against the
native? So in step two you figure out
how do these things work well for the
native and in step three you figure out
how do they work against the native or
if in step two you first started
thinking about how they work against the
native then do the opposite and step
three think how they would work for the
native so for example the openness of
Jupiter in the 10th house how could that
work against somebody well you could be
overrevealing you can't keep
secrets you can't really be tactful
maybe even because you just are very
open. Things just come out unmodified,
unedited to
direct. Also, when you're very ethical
and moral and
lawful, we sort of expect the rest of
the world to be like we are. So, you can
be overly trusting and you can get
suckered and scammed. Let's look at this
next thing. Wise leadership implies that
Jupiter in the 10th is, for example, a
good parent, a good guide, a good
teacher. How could that work against a
person? You could wind up being a person
that's
overprotective. You're too
coddling. And how about this third
thing? Good character, ideal behavior.
How could that work against a
person? Well, one thing is if you're
very into proper behavior, that can make
you closed to other possible ways of
acting. So it can make you
close-minded. You might not be able to
identify that some other type of
behavior is also
okay. And another thing is when you're
very ideal and idealistic, you can
become ethically
handicapped. By which I don't really
mean you have bad ethics, but I mean
that your
ethics work against you.
So, for example, like you're a musician
and somebody offers you $5 million to
put your song in their commercial and
you turn it down because it's against
your ethics. Big business or something
is against your
ethics. So, now we've sorted out
positive and negative implications of
the planet in the house. Now we come to
step four where we have to make a
decision of how positive or how negative
is this particular interpretation for
this particular chart. So basically all
that you really need to do is know how
positive or negative this Jupiter is in
the chart and that directly informs you
how much emphasis you place on the
positive implications versus how much
emphas you put on the negative
implications.
So then the big question is how do you
decide how positive or negative Jupiter
is? Well, there's many factors involved,
but I'll tell you the three most
crucial. So first of all, the most
important factor determining whether or
not this planet is positive or negative
in this house is the sign that the
planet occupies in the house.
because that sign causes the planet to
have positive or negative dignity. So
for example, let's say Jupiter is in
cancer in the 10th house. Well, it's
exalted if it's in cancer. Therefore,
it's completely positive. So in that
case, you would give zero emphasis to
the negative permutations or
implications of this interpretation and
all the emphasis to the positive ones.
If however Jupiter wasn't in cancer, it
was in Capricorn in the 10th house, then
it would be in
fall, which means it would have zero
dignity. So you would give no emphasis
to the positive implications of Jupiter
in the 10th house and all the emphasis
to the negative implications. So
exaltation and fall are the two extremes
of dignity. There's a full spectrum in
between those two extremes. And I've
released recently three or four videos
exploring that and teaching you in
detail how to figure it out. So you can
go back and watch those videos to learn
how to calculate the dignity accurately.
Once you have the dignity of this planet
in this sign in the house, the next
thing you want to consider is the impact
of the house itself on the planet's
dignity. because different types of
planets have a easier or more difficult
time being dignified in different types
of
houses. So luckily there's really only
two groups of planets in this regard.
The first are the malefific and along
with the malefific will include the sun
and the nodes.
These planets find it more difficult to
be dignified when they're in the first,
fourth, fifth, or
ninth, but they find it easier to be
dignified if they're in the 3rd, 6th,
10th, or 11th. The rest of the planets
are the bonificics along with the moon
and mercury. These planets find it
easier to be dignified when they're in
the first, fourth, fifth, 9inth, or
tenth. And they have a more difficult
time being dignified if they are in the
third or the sixth. So to quantify this
more or lessness than I'm talking about
here, if they have a more difficult time
being dignified, subtract 25 from their
dignity. And if they have an easier time
being dignified in this particular
house, add 25 to it. Let me show you how
this works in two examples. We'll take
the example of Jupiter in Cancer in the
3rd house and Saturn in Aries in the
10th. So now let's start with Jupiter in
Cancer in the third house. Since it's in
Cancer, we think that its dignity is
100% positive. So we're giving all the
stress to the positive implications.
You're wellinformed. You're efficient in
your action. You're very cooperative and
inclusive and fair. and you're generous
and sharing with your peers. However,
this is the third house. So, Jupiter
being a
bonific has a
handicap towards being dignified when
it's in this third house, which is a
house that's more oriented or suited
towards malefific. So, even though it's
in cancer, we have to reduce its
functional dignity from 100% down to
75%.
So in the interpretation we would start
to see some of the negative traits that
are possible from Jupiter in the third
house. It wouldn't be overwhelming the
positive traits but they would be kind
of flaws that are somewhat there in the
person's
behavior. What kind of flaws are those?
Well, it's selfishness, disobedience,
competitiveness,
uncooperation,
calculiveness, and
stinginess. So, this would these kind of
flaws would be coexisting with their
generosity and cooperiveness. So, they
would get picky under certain
circumstances or only with certain
people they would be generous, but with
other people not. So that's an example
of how the house affects the dignity for
Jupiter in the third in cancer. Let's
look at it kind of the opposite way.
Let's look at Saturn and Aries in the
10th house. So the positive traits of
Saturn in the 10th is you are a expert
in managing people and understanding how
people work, dealing with the masses and
therefore you're very good with
politics. Also you have a very strong
practical rationality, objectivity and
logic and you are an
underdog who can overcome odds and
therefore you can inspire people a lot.
Those are the positive implications of
Saturn in the 10th. The negative
implications are rebelliousness like out
of control rebelliousness. Being hyper
critical of anybody else who's a leader
or anybody else who's your boss. Being
very insensitive due to your logic and
rationality and dispassion and so forth
and just being exhausted, overworking
yourself. So which of these two
polarities of Saturn and the 10th should
we
emphasize? Well, first of all, since
it's in Aries, we think we're just going
to emphasize 100% on the negative.
However, since Saturn is in the 10th,
which is good for a
malefific, it gets a bonus to its
dignity, 25%. So, it reduces the
negativity from 100% to 75%. So, we
start to see the positive qualities of
Saturn coming out. So yeah, this person
is hyper critical of other leaders and
bosses, but at least they're pretty good
at managing people on their own. Or
yeah, this person is exhausted and
overworking, but they're also inspiring
and they're an underdog. Now, we've seen
the impact of the sign on the dignity
and also we've seen the impact of the
house. There's one more consideration
which is
crucial. It's the impact of the lordship
of a planet.
If a planet is the lord of the whole
chart, in other words, the lord of the
first house, then it's easier for it to
be dignified in that chart. Why? Because
it doesn't want to mess up any area of
the chart. It doesn't want to mess up
any house because all the houses belong
to it ultimately because it is the lord
of the
first. So if a planet is a lord of the
first house, you give it a 20% bonus to
its functioning dignity.
If it is the lord of a trine, the fifth
or the ninth, then you give it another
bonus, smaller bonus, 15% bonus, because
those are good houses that try to
benefit other
people. Also, if it is the lord of the
fourth or the 10th, you give it a small
bonus of five.
However, if it's the lord of the sixth,
8th, or 12th, you're going to give it a
handicap because the lords of these
houses tend to be grumpy and tend to
mess up the places that they visit.
Let's take a look at this in action
using our same examples. First of all,
Jupiter and Cancer in the third house.
So, if Cancer is the third, then Pisces
is the 11th and Sagittarius is the
eighth. Well, the 11th doesn't give you
a bonus or a penalty, but being the lord
of the eighth house does give you a
penalty. So, we would have to further
subtract 15 more positivity points from
Jupiter in the third house in Cancer and
that would bring up the negative
implications further and tone down the
positive implications.
Let's look at this one more time with
the example of Saturn and Aries in the
10th. If Aries is the 10th house, then
Saturn's signs Aquarius and Capricorn
are the eighth and the 7th. Again, we
don't care about being the lord of the
seventh, but we care about being the
lord of the eighth because that gives us
a
15% handicap to our dignity, our
functional dignity. So although Saturn
kind of improved a bit by the virtue of
it being in the 10th house which is good
for malefific it then slides back again
because it is the lord of the eighth
house. Now before we leave this topic I
want to uh make sure that you understand
one significant loophole about 6 8 and
12 and that handicap. The loophole is if
the planet
occupies the 6th 8th or 12th
and it is the lord of the 6th 8th or
12th then that handicap turns around
into an asset turns around to a benefit.
So for example if Saturn was in Aries
not in the 10th house but in the eighth
house then its signs Aquarius and
Capricorn would be the fifth and the
sixth
houses. That would mean that it's
getting 15 bonus from being the lord of
a trine and it's getting 15 bonus by
being the lord of the six the dustana
while it occupies the eighth another
dust. So instead of having 100%
negativity it would actually only have
70% negativity in the eighth house. So
using these four steps you can really
clearly understand how to interpret any
planet in any house not just in the main
chart but also in any house-based sable
subchart like navam sapsha and so on. If
you want me to do that for you or if you
want to know exactly how I would do it
in your case for your chart you can find
that out. I have my report available on
my website victcare.com. Click on
readings and then add whichever modules
you want. Enter your birth data and
order the chart. Thank you so much.